wow master will das hat mich mit diesem
bild wieder hier komplett überzeugt
salome messflug und herzlich willkommen
zu einer weiteren folge master bilder da
mittlerweile jeder youtuber zehnmal
täglich meist aber dass hochlädt und ich
eigentlich der hat er mich da hinten
gerade weggeschickt jeder weiß es in
minecraft kann sich keiner mit mir
messen das hat man auch in der pvp
tricks mit luca folge gesehen
mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zur ersten folge von pvp
tricks
ich bin gestorben deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich zeigte ihm hier immer noch
mal genau wie das alles funktioniert
übrigens hier komme ich hab meinen
merchandise an den kann man aber derzeit
nicht bestellen war der leider wieder
komplett ausverkauft ist kauft alle
menschen als balu calista village.de
im master builders geht es darum dass
wir etwas vorgegeben bekommen und wir
haben dann mit allen verfügbaren glocken
dies gibt fünf minuten zeit und das
ganze in minecraft nachzubauen das ganze
geht jetzt in 98 7 master will das wird
luca das gamestar tag genau jetzt und
wir müssen ein
stalking
erst mal ganz kurz noch mal nachgucken
was doping ist für die leute schreiben
enthält auch schon so wtf stalking
stalking ist ein strom
ach die haben das jetzt bestimmt so
winter mäßig pseudo scheiße ich baue den
strumpf jetzt mal einfach so als wäre
das wirklich auf den winter bezogen also
sondern so ein bisschen hiermit mit rot
weiß und rot weiß hört sich wie ketchup
mayo an der erste schon getwittert hat
einfach keinen bock mit hofft was mich
bei diesem spielmodus am meisten ab fakt
ist einfach die tatsache dass ist nur
für leute gemacht ist die wirklich
aufbauen können so einer wie ich hat
dann natürlich komplett gar nichts
verloren
der nächste schon wieder gekittet alter
das ist nicht wahr nachher gewinne ich
noch reifer war keiner mehr da ist meine
grobi die wäre halt gewesen dass ich das
ganze hier so ein bisschen rot weiß
machte wie sonnenstrom wie man den quasi
vom zwei minuten nur noch und mein strom
fertig
an alle hater ja das ist ein strumpf da
sehen wir jetzt immer gerade was die
anderen gebaut haben es ist stocking und
das ist definitiv ja das programm also
freunde wenn ich sehe was die hier so
gebaut haben dann ist es a
obwohl das soll ja wahrscheinlich ein
stromer vorm kamin sein soso lp starker
nach nur das hier ist definitiv kein
strumpf sondern pinocchio oder ein typ
der raucht das hier ist tatsächlich dass
es trotz dass das jeder mit diesem kamin
gebaut hat wieso bin ich darauf nicht
gekommen freunde jetzt mal ganz
unvoreingenommen aber das was ich jetzt
gerade sehe ich das allergrößte wasser
weil das hier gesehen habe also mein
strömt ist ja auch schon geil aber guckt
euch diesen strom fahren dem bild bei
con kräfte war
die müsste ich definitiv mal auf youtube
auschecken danach mache und er hat sogar
viel schöner gemacht als ich und sogar
mit süßigkeiten drin und zum mann
ich wurde vierter ich will doch nur
einmal aufs podest und das nächste was
wir bauen müssen ist eine familie
alles klar ich schaue master builders
bei anderen leuten an und sie so ja wir
bauen eine pizza wir bauen
wir bauen einen fußball ich wusste
familie bauen jeder 08 15 master wilders
spieler youtuber wird jetzt sagen ja
komm ich mache eine blöde kleine familie
baut die eben was macht luca ich baue
die krippe von jesus und von den linke
schafen und den hirten wegen weihnachten
also ich versuche mich echt immer so ein
bisschen jetzt gerade sogar anzustrengen
ich das jetzt denkt dass sie eine minute
oder ach du heilige scheiße
ok ich muss noch schnell links an tollen
sprüchen schreiben wie families
ich dachte mit so einem tollen tumblr
spruch kriege ich die dann alle ok ich
wollte eigentlich auch baby billiger
machen allerdings hat das nicht so ganz
geklappt bei mir bei ihm hier allerdings
irgendwie schon normalerweise stellt man
sich natürlich eine familie bestehend
aus mehreren personen vor
hier ist eine person auf einer bank
maia bleeding normalerweise stellt man
sich eine familie vorderster mehrere
menschen sind hier sind einfach
seine familie alter jetzt wieder jemand
komplett auf den punkt getroffen mit der
familie also wirklich hätte sich um
weihnachten gekümmert und schaut euch
das an das ist doch einfach wundervoll
das ist der family sorry hef trittin
like ich fertig geworden zwei master
builders hat mich mit diesem bild wieder
hier komplett überzeugt
super schöne familie maia bleeding also
hier auch wieder das ist doch reine was
haltet ihr davon
da
dann ist doch eine wunderschöne familie
oder mal ganz kurz nach hilfe mit luca
eine familie besteht nicht aus nur einer
person
denn nur mit volltrottel hier wieder
zusammen
warum kann ich nicht mal irgendwann top3
werden da das video jetzt wieder vorbei
ist und heute der elfte dezember ist
mache ich jetzt eben noch als das ist
ich war ich wollte eigentlich immer
mitten im video aufmachen aber jetzt
habe
walter ich bereue es ehrlich gesagt dass
ich mir diesen kalender gekauft habe und
nicht den hier dass es ein model
kalender wir haben heute im elften
türchen
wir brauchen einen namen für die schreib
mir mal namensvorschläge für sie hier
und in die kommentare und dann schaue
ich mal was davon ganz gut ist und dann
benennen wir die danach und die kommt
nicht in den akinator bevor sie nicht
einen namen hat das lieblingshobby von
ihr ist übrigens
abhängen was sie allerdings auch sehr
gerne macht ist ab stützen
dieses ganz schön sportlich ja meine
lieben freunde wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen wollt ihr vielleicht
nochmal master will das von mir sehen
ich habe jetzt seit dem es draußen ist
seit einem halben jahr ca zweimal
gespielt sonst würde ich sagen schreib
mir tolle namen für den rotschopf daran
die kommentare und dann sehen wir uns